Merhaba sevgili öğrenciler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Bu dersimizde 6. sınıfın 9.
ünitesi olan Life in City or Country,
Şehirde ya da kırsalda hayat adlı
üniteyi hep birlikte işleyeceğiz. Life
in city country, şehirde, kırsalda yaşam
adlı üniteyi hep birlikte işleyeceğiz.
Bu dersimizde önemli kelimeler ve önemli
dil bilgisi kurallarını birlikte teker
teker inceleyeceğiz. Eğer bu ünite ile
ilgili alıştırmalar, testler, denemeler
çözmek istiyorsanız, öğrendiğiniz
kelimeleri oyunlarla pekiştirmek
istiyorsanız, Play Store ve App
Store'dan Justin Academ uygulamasını
ücretsiz bir şekilde indirip
kullanabilirsiniz.
Kalem ve kağıdınız hazırsa bu
dersimizdeki önemli kelimeleri öğrenmeye
başlıyoruz. Aberin, patlıcan.
Cujet, kabak,
mushroom. Mantar.
Salmon som balığı
be. Fasulye.
Bell pepper dolmalık biber.
Lentle mercimek
time. Kekik.
Wi buğday.
Vegetable
sebze.
Fruit meyve.
Grain. Tahıl.
Cereal gevrek
vinegar sirke.
Olive oil zeytinyağı
tuna, tom balığı
coconut hindistan cevizi.
Pineapple ananas
seafood deniz ürünleri.
Taco.
Sweet corn.
Tatlı mısır
biscu bisküvi.
Beef sığreti.
Sweet tatlı.
Brows et tavuk suyu.
Soup çorba
duck ördek
herb. Bitki
lemçap kuzu pirzola.
Noodle şerit halinde makarna erişte.
Pasta makarna
kuskus
pastry hamur işi.
Mince kıyma
rice pirinç
onion soğan.
Nut kabuklu yemiş.
Walnut ceviz
pistaio. Fıstık ante fıstığı
pepper flakes.
Toz biber.
Barbecue mangal
burger. Hamburger.
Curry. Curry.
Fluffle. Nohut köftesi.
Adjectives sıfatlar demektir. Bu ünitede
bulunan ve önemli olan bilmeniz gereken
sıfatlar şunlardır.
Creamy kremalı.
Giant büyük kocaman.
Hot sıcak juicy sulu. Salty tuzlu.
Bitter acı.
Savy tuzlu atıştırmalık işte haçıcı.
Sour ekşi.
Tender yumuşak
stuffed tıka basa dolu. Crispy çıtır
çıtır gevrek.
Chewy çiğnenebilir.
Tropic tropikal.
Smoky dumanlı.
Sıfatları bitirdik. Sırada önemli
kelimeler var. Important words, önemli
kelimeler.
Fair, panayır, fuar.
Feast festival
ingredients. Malzemeler
local yerel
regional bölgesel
stall tezgah.
Taste tat zevk
vender satıcı tedarikçi.
Flavor tat duygusu, lezzet.
Spoon kaşık
apron önlük.
Grill ızgara
bake fırında pişirmek.
Host ev sahibi.
Offer teklif vermek ars teklif.
Attend katılmak
mutfak
diş yemek
stew yani kaynatmak.
Stir karıştırmak
marinate. Marine etmek sosta bekletmek.
Season baharatlandırmak.
Social language sosyal dil demektir. Bu
ünite ile ilgili günlük hayatta
kullanılan kalıplar şunlardır.
Eğer bir şey için bunun tadı harika
diyeceksek this tastes amazing
diyebiliriz. Ya da ne lezzetli bir
yemek. What a delicious meal. I full
but I can't stop eating. Doydum ama
yemeden duramıyorum. Çok lezzetli bir
şey için de bu ifadeyi
kullanabilirsiniz.
Eğer yemek yapmakta iyisin ya da yemek
yapmakta kötüsün demek istiyorsak you
are good at cooking diyebiliriz ya da
you are bad at cooking diyebiliriz.
Bu ünite içerisinde değinmemiz gereken
önemli ama çok küçük bir ifade var. O da
or kelimesi. Or karşıdaki insanlara
seçenek sunarken kullandığımız Türkçede
ya da anlamına gelen ifadedir. Do you
prefer to visit the food stalls or
attend the life music performance? Sen
yemek standlarını mı ziyaret etmeyi
tercih edersin yoksa canlı müzik
performanslarına katılmayı mı?
Gördüğünüz gibi karşıdaki insana iki
tane seçenek sunuluyor. Ya da anlamı
katabilmek için orız. Does the concert
start at 7 pm or 8 pm? Konser akşam
700'de mi başlıyor yoksa 8'de mi?
Gördüğünüz gibi bu yoksa anlamını
katabilmek için or kelimesine
ihtiyacımız var. Bu indeki kazanımların
bizden tekrar etmemizi, tekrar
öğrenmemizi istediği bir konu var. O da
simple present tense yani geniş zaman ve
present progressive tense. Şimdiki
zamanın karşılaştırması. Aslında biz
önceki derslerimizde bu iki zamanı da en
ince ayrıntısına kadar işledik. Burada
kısaca kıyaslayacağız. Daha sonra ben
sizin için önemli olduğundan dolayı bu
anlatım videolarını tekrardan buraya
ekleyeceğim. Geniş zamandan bahsederken
yani present simple tense'ten
bahsederken genel geçer bir doğrudan ya
da rutinden ya da alışkanlıktan
bahsetmemiz lazım. Genel geçer doğrular
şunlardır. Güneşin her zaman doğudan
doğması. Mesela suyun her zaman 100
derecede kaynaması. Rutinlerimiz her
sabah uyandığımızda dişlerimizi
fırçalamamız ya da her perşembe günü
gitar kursuna gitmemiz. Böyle bir şeyden
bahsediyorsak simple present tense
kullanırız. Ama bir şeyi şimdi şu an
yapıyorsak bundan bahsederken present
progressive tense yani şimdiki şu anki
zamanı kullanırız. Festivallerden
bahsederken de bu iki zaman çok sık bir
şekilde kullanılır. Mesela bir
festivalden bahsederken eğer rutin
haline gelmişse geniş zaman kullanırız.
Mesela the city host a grand music
festival in august every year. Şehir her
yıl Ağustos ayında büyük bir müzik
festivaline ev sahipliği yapıyor. Bunu
artık her yıl yaptığı için bu bir rutine
dönüşmüş. Burada geniş zaman
kullanabiliriz. Şu an şimdiki zaman
kullanacağımız bir örnek verelim. Two
band are separate stages right now. Şu
anda iki grup ayrı sahnelerde çalıyor.
Şu an şimdi meydana geldiği için şimdiki
zaman kullandık. Eğer bir cümle
içerisinde zıtlık belirteceksek iki
zamanı birden kullanabiliriz. Bunu
bağlaçlarla yaparız. They are usually
hold the festival outdoors. Onlar
genellikle festivalleri dışarıda
yaparlar. Gördüğünüz gibi genellikle
yaptıkları için bir rutine bindiği için
burada geniş zaman kullandık. However,
ama they are moving the activities
indoors due to heavy rain. Yoğun yağmur
sebebiyle aktivitelerini bugün içeriye
taşıdılar. Şu an şimdi bugün
yaptıklarından dolayı ikinci tarafta da
şimdiki zaman kullandık. Bir de double
ed question dediğimiz soru cümleleri
vardır. Soru cümlelerinde genellikle
geniş zaman kullanılır. İki farklı
şekilde de verilmiş cümleyi inceleyelim.
Why is Adana so special when it comes to
food? Konu yemek olduğunda Adana neden
bu kadar özeldir? Gördüğünüz gibi bu
genel geçer bir doğrudur ve genel geçer
bir kanı olduğundan dolayı geniş zaman
kullandık. Ama aynı şekilde şu an şimdi
ne yapıldığını soruyorsak what are the
women over cooking? Oradaki kadınlar ne
pişiriyorlar? Gördüğünüz gibi bu da
şimdiki zamana ait bir soru cümlesidir.
İki zamanın karşılaştırılmasında genel
olarak şunu düşüneceksiniz. Bir şey
rutin mi, alışkanlık mı? Genel geçer bir
doğru mu yoksa şu an şimdi yapılıyor mu?
Bunlardan bahsederken genellikle zaten
zaman cümleleri kullanılır. Mesela geniş
zaman için usually, always, never gibi
ifadeler kullanılır. Her zaman, daima,
asla. Ama şimdiki zaman için today,
bugün, now, şu an, şimdi tarzı ifadeler
kullanılır. Bu konuları hatırlamanız
için şimdi ayrıntısıyla ders videolarını
tekrardan ekliyorum. Dersin devamında
izleyebilirsiniz. Simple present tense
yani Türkçe versiyonuyla geniş zaman.
İngilizcede her zaman karşınıza çıkacak
en temel konulardan bir tanesidir. Hatta
İngilizce öğrenmeye başlayanların kalem
defteri eline alarak ilk öğrendiği konu
simple present tense. Her yerde
anlatılan ilk konu da budur. İngilizcede
bu kadar önemli olan, en temel olan ve
en çok kullanılan bu zamanı niçin, neden
ve nerede kullanıyoruz? En basit ve en
kolay haliyle anlatacağım. Hiç telaş
yok. Hep birlikte çok rahat bir şekilde
öğreneceğiz. Peki her zaman duyacağımız
bu efsanevi geniş zaman nedir? Nerede
kullanacağız? Bu zaman bizim ne işimize
yarayacak? Teker teker inceleyelim.
Sürekli ya da belli aralıklarla
yaptığımız bir iş varsa bundan
bahsederken simple present tense
kullanacağız. Örneğin siz her çarşamba
günü gitar kursuna gidiyorsanız
gördüğünüz gibi belli aralıklarla ama
düzenli yapıyorsunuz. Bu yüzden burada
geniş zaman kullanmalısınız. Ya da bir
şeyi sürekli yapıyorsanız mesela her
sabah dişlerinizi fırçalıyorsanız bundan
bahsederken yine geniş zaman
kullanacağız.
Değişmeyen durumlardan ve duygulardan
bahsederken yine geniş zaman kullanılır.
Herkes tarafından bilinen gerçekleri
anlatırken yine geniş zaman kullanırız.
Mesela güneş doğudan doğar, batıdan
batar. Bu herkes tarafından bilinen,
kabul edilen bir gerçektir. Bundan
bahsederken geniş zaman kullanacağız.
kullanımını anladığımıza göre yavaş
yavaş cümle yapılarına geçiş
yapabiliriz. Pitif form olumlu hal
demektir. Eğer biz geniş zamanı
kullanarak olumlu cümle elde etmek
istiyorsak bunu şu şekilde yapacağız.
Öncelikle bir özne ile başlayacağız.
Ben demektir. We, biz, you, sen, siz,
they onlar demektir.
Bu dört özne ile birlikte geniş zaman
kullanacaksak her zaman fiilin birinci
hali yani ek almamış, yalın hali
kullanılır. Örneğin, I play soccer every
weekend. Ben her hafta sonu futbol
oynarım. Gördüğünüz gibi ben demektir ve
her hafta sonu düzenli yaptığım bir
işten bahsedeceğim. Bunu yaparken play
oynamak fiilini kullanıyorum ve fiile
hiçbir şey eklemiyorum. Önemli olan
budur. Fiil hiçbir ek almaz. We go
holiday summer. Biz her yazın tatile
gidiyoruz. Bu her yaz mevsiminde düzenli
olarak yaptığımız bir eylem. Bundan
bahsederken we öznesinden sonra eğer
fiil kullanacaksak fiil hiçbire
kalmayacak. Yalın haliyle kullanılacak.
They drink coffee twice a day. Onlar
günde iki kere kahve içiyorlar. Bunları
sürekli yapıyorlar. O halde they
özesinden sonra drink içmek fiilini
kullandığımızda geniş zaman olduğundan
dolayı hiçbir ek kullanmayacağız. Direkt
yalın haliyle yazacağız. Ali and Mehmet
visit their parents on Fridays. Cuma
günleri Ali ve Mehmet ailelerini ziyaret
ediyorlar. Burada dikkat etmeniz gereken
şey özellikle şu. Çoğul öznelerde fiil
yine hiçbire kalmaz. Özellikle bu örneği
yazdım. Gördüğünüz gibi Ali ve Mehmet
iki kişi yani çoğul. Çoğul olduğu
durumlarda fiil yine hiçbir ek almaz.
Yani visit, ziyaret etmek fiiline
eklemedik. Olduğu haliyle kullandık. The
birds fly very fast. Kuşlar çok hızlı
bir şekilde uçuyorlar. Birds kuşlar
demektir. S çoğul ekini almıştır. Çoğul
öznelerde ne yapıyorduk? Az önce
söylediğim gibi heili hiçbir
eklemiyoruz. Çünkü çoğul zaten.
Elephants live in Asya Africa. Hiller
Asya ve Afrika'da yaşarlar. Bunu sürekli
yapıyorlar. Bu onların yaşam alanı
değişmeyen bir durum var. Bundan
bahsederken geniş zaman kullanacağız.
Elephants. Fiiller çoğul olduğundan
dolayı live yaşamak fiiline hiç birek
eklemedik. Geriye kalan özneleri teker
teker inceleyelim.
He erkekler için kullanılır, o demektir.
She, kızlar için kullanılır, o demektir.
It cansız ve hayvanlarda kullanılır, o
demektir. Bunlardan sonra geniş zamanda
fiil kullanacaksak oldukça önemli nokta
s takısı kullanacağız. Zaten bütün
sınavlarda, bütün yazılılarda çıkan
nokta, sorulan yer burası. He, she ve it
öznesi varsa bir kızdan, bir erkekten,
bir hayvandan cansız bir şeyden
bahsediyorsak tekilse bununlar fiile s
takısı ekleyeceğiz.
Celine hates broccoli. Celin brokoliden
nefret ediyor, hoşlanmıyor. Selin she
özdesi yani kız özdesi yerine geçiyor.
Bundan sonraki fiile taks eklemek
zorundayız. Geniş zamanda her zaman
sevmediği değişmeyen bir duygu,
değişmeyen bir durum var. Bu yüzden
bundan bahsederken geniş zaman
kullanıyoruz. Ama önemli olan noktası
Selin de kız olduğu için fiile s takısı
ekleyeceğiz.
He watches TV after school. Okuldan
sonra o televizyon izliyor. He erkek
özesinden sonra geniş zamanda fiile s
takısı ekleyeceğiz. Bu s takısının
kullanımı ile ilgili kuralları ayrıntılı
bir şekilde ilerleyen dakikalarda
göreceğiz. O yüzden şimdi kafanızda şu
oluşmuş olabilir. Neden sadece s
eklemedik de e harfini de kullandık?
Bunu birazdan ayrıntılı bir şekilde
anlatacağım. Its cheese. O peynir yer.
It yemek demektir. It özesi ile birlikte
geniş zamanda kullanacaksak s takısı
alır. Az önce bahsettiğim gibi S
takısını geniş zamanda kullanmanın belli
başlı kuralları var. Bu S takısını bazen
sadece s olarak bazen e ve s olarak veya
i, e ve s olarak kullanabiliriz.
Bunların kuralları şudur. Eğer
bahsettiğimiz fiilin sonunda iki tane S
harfi varsa S ve H, C ve H, iki tane Z
harfi, X veya O varsa bunlardan sonra S
takısı eklerken E harfi ile birlikte
ekleyeceğiz. Tekrar ediyorum, eğer
fiilimizin sonu bahsettiğim harflerle
bitiyorsa bunlardan sonra S takısı
eklerken E ve S'yi birlikte yazacağız.
Örnekleri inceleyelim.
Pass geçmek demektir. İki tane s
harfiyle bitiyor. Yani buna s takısı
eklerken e harfini de yazacağız. Baz
gördüğünüz gibi iki tane zile bitiyor.
Buna s takısı eklerken e harfinde
yazacağız. Ve en çok kullanılanı go
gitmek fiili. Buna eğer s takısı
ekleyeceksek e harfini de unutmayacağız.
Çünkü sonu o harfiyle bitiyor. Crash
gördüğünüz gibi s ve hile bitiyor. Bunun
sonuna S takısı ekleyeceksek E ve S'yi
birlikte yazacağız. Aynısı fix kelimesi
için de geçerli. İkinci kuralda ise eğer
fiil sessiz bir harf ve artı y harfi ile
bitiyorsa i harfi, e harfi ve s harfini
birlikte kullanacağız. Buna şu şekilde
örnekler verelim. Örneğin cry ağlamak
demektir. Y harfinden önce R harfi de
ünsüzdür yani sessizdir.
O halde buna s takısı eklerken ii
yazacağız, y harfi düşecek. E ve s'yi
yazacağız. Fly uçmak fiili. Y harfinden
önce L harfi ünsüz yani sessizdir.
Buna takısı eklerken Y harfini
yazmayacağız. I yazdıktan sonra E ve
S'yi birlikte yazacağız. Study en fazla
kullanılanlardan bir tanesidir. Y'den
önce D harfi var. Sessizdir yani
ünsüzdür. O halde S takısı gelirken Y
harfi düşecek. I yazacağız. E yazdıktan
sonra s yazacağız. Ama burada önemli bir
nokta var. Y harfinden önce eğer ünlü
bir harf varsa o zaman Y harfini
düşürmemize gerek yok. Yani y harfinden
öncekine bakacağız. Eğer ünlüyse
düşürmeden sadece s yazacağız. Eğer
ünsüzse düşüreceğiz. I yazdıktan sonra E
ve S yazacağız. Geriye kalan bütün
fiiller sadece s harfi alır. Play,
plays, run, runs, stay, stays, jump,
jumps. Eğer bu iki kurala dikkat
ederseniz geriye kalan bütün fiillerde
sıkısını yazıp geçeceğiz. Negative form
olumsuz hal demektir. Bütün öznelere
göre olumlu halleri işledik. Şimdi
sırada olumsuz yani negatif halleri var.
Eğer geniş zamanda olumsuz bir cümle
kurmak istiyorsak şunlara dikkat
edeceğiz. Cümleye yine bir özne ile
başlayacağız. Öznelerimiz,
we, you ve they. Bunlardan sonra geniş
zamanda olumsuzluk eki don'tur. Don't
yazdıktan sonra yine fiili
değiştirmeyeceğiz. Olduğu haliyle
yazacağız. Zaten bu dört özne de fiil
hiçbir zaman ek almaz. Olumsuz
yaptığımızda da don't kullanırız. I
don't go to school by bus. Ben okula
otobüste gitmem. Özdesinden sonra geniş
zamanda olumsuz yaparken don't
kullanırız. Go to gitmek fiiline zaten
hiçbir şey eklemiyoruz. Olduğu haliyle
kullanıyoruz.
London. Biz Londra'da yaşamıyoruz. We
öznesinden sonra olumsuz yaparken don't
negatiflik ekini kullanırız. Daha sonra
live yaşamak fiiline hiçbir eklemeyiz.
Leyla and Ceylan don't swim in the sea.
Leyla ve Ceylan denizde yüzmüyorlar.
Gördüğünüz gibi çoğal öznedir. İki tane
insandan bahsediyoruz. Geniş zamanda
olumsuz yaparken don't negatiflik ekini
kullanacağız. Daha sonra swim yüzmek
fiiline hiçbir şey eklemeyeceğiz.
Gelelim en çok sınavlarda sorulan ve en
çok hata yapılan kısma. Geriye kalan
özneler he, she ve it özneleri. Biz bunu
olumlu halde anlatırken fiil s takısı
alır dedik ama şimdi olumsuz halde
doesn't da zaten s takısı olduğu için
fiili hiçbir şey eklememize gerek yok.
Tekrar ediyorum çünkü çok önemli. Geniş
zamanda he, she ve it öznelerinde eğer
cümleyi olumsuz yapacaksak yani doesn't
kullanacaksak ile de hiçbir şey
eklemiyoruz. Hiç karışmıyoruz. Çünkü
zaten doesn'tda s takısı var. Kısacası
fiil olumsuz ve soru cümlese fiile s
takısı eklemiyoruz. Örnekleri
inceleyelim.
He doesn't work at the weekend. O hafta
sonları çalışmaz. He erkekler için
kullanılır. Olumsuz yapacaksak doesn't
kullanırız. Geniş zamanda olumsuz
cümlede doesn't kullanırsak eğer fiili
değiştirmiyoruz. Olduğu haliyle
yazıyoruz. She doesn't get up early. O
erken kalkmaz. Geniş zamanda she
öznesdesinde olumsuz yaparken doesn't
kullanacağız. Do kullandığımız için de
dili değiştirmeyeceğiz.
It doesn't snow in summer. Yazın kar
yağmaz. It özesinden sonra olumsuz
yaparken doesn't kullandık. Do olduğu
için fiile karışmadık. Question form
soru hali demektir. Eğer geniş zamanda
soru cümlesi oluşturacaksak şöyle
yapmalıyız. Cümleye bu kez do yardımcı
ekiyile başlayacağız. Ama do'yu
kullandığımız özneler şunlar. I, we, you
ve they. Bunlardan sonra fiile hiçbir
şey eklemiyoruz. Cümlenin sonuna da soru
işareti koyuyoruz.
Örneğin, "Do you take a piano course?"
Sen piyano kursu alıyor musun?
Do ile başladık ve öznemiz you. Eğer
alıyorsa yes, ı, doğmıyorsa
no, ı don't demeliyiz. Geriye kalan
özneler için inceleyelim. Does
kullandıktan sonra he, she ve it
öznelerini kullanırız. Does olduğu için
yine fiile herhangi bir eklemiyoruz.
Olduğu haliyle kullanıyoruz. Dans'tan
sonra sonuna soru işareti koyduk mu
güzel bir cümle elde etmiş oluruz.
Dikkat etmeniz gereken şeyi tekrar
belirtiyorum. He, she ve it öznelerinde
negatif cümlelerde doesn't olduğu için
ve soru cümlelerinde does olduğu için he
ile karışmıyoruz.
Does he clean home? O evi temizler mi?
Eğer temizliyorsa yes, he does. Ama eğer
temizlemiyorsa no, he doesn't
kullanmalıyız. Time expressions zaman
ifadeleri demektir. Geniş zamanda
kullanabileceğimiz zaman kelimeleri
şunlardır. Bir kere düzenli olarak ya da
belli aralıklarla yaptığımız işlerden
bahsettiğimiz için every day, her gün,
every week, her hafta ya da every month,
her ay, every year, her yıl ifadelerini
kullanabiliriz. Herhangi bir gün ismi de
kullanabiliriz. On Fridays cuma günleri
ya da on saturdays cumartesileri.
At night ya da nights geceleyin
geceleri. At weekends en çok kullanılanı
hafta sonları. On bir kere demektir.
Once a month ayda bir kere. Once a week
haftada bir kere. Twice iki kere
demektir. Twice a week. Haftada iki
kere. Three times a year. Yılda 3 kere.
Bu tarz zaman ifadelerini de cümlenin
sonunda kullanabilirsiniz.
Sırada tag questions yapıları var. Tag
question teyit etme soruları demektir.
Yani İngilizcede söylediğimiz bir şeyin
doğru olup olmadığını anlamak veya
birinden onay almak istiyorsak sonuna
kısa sorular ekleriz. Bunlara da
question yapılır deriz. Doğru mu? Değil
mi? katılıyor musun gibi anlamlar verir.
Cümlenin bir tarafı olumluysa ikinci
kısım olumsuz olur. Tam tersi durumda
cümlenin ilk kısmı olumsuzsa diğer kısım
ise olumlu olur. Kısacası göz atalım.
She is cooking dinner, isn't she? O şu
an akşam yemeği pişiriyor, değil mi?
Gördüğünüz gibi is yardımcı eki ilk
kısımda olumlu kullanıldığı için ikinci
kısımda olumsuz olur ve isn't şeklinde
yazılır. They are watching TV. Aren't
they? Onlar televizyon izliyorlar değil
mi? Gördüğünüz gibi are yardımcı eki
burada olumlu olduğu için ikinci kısma
bunu soru olarak ekleyeceğiz. Bu kez
olumsuz yapacağız ve arzacağız.
I taking a photo. Ar. Ben fotoğraf
çekiyorum değil mi? Burada dikkat
etmeniz gereken kısım 'dan sonra
kullanılır. Olumludur. Ama am'i diğer
tarafta olumsuz olarak kullanacaksak
arız.
Yani I diğer kısımda arı olur. Bu
genelde sınavlarda çıkar. Bu yüzden
burada dikkat edin.
Eğer ilk kısım olumsuzsa bu kez ikinci
kısım olumlu olacak. You aren't draw a
picture, are you? Sen resim çizmiyorsun,
değil mi? Yardımcı ek olan arkda olumsuz
olduğu için ikinci kısımda olumlu olarak
are şeklinde yazılır. Tag questionin
yapıları kısaca bu şekildedir.
Karşımızdaki insana değil mi, katılıyor
musun ya da doğru mu diye sormak
istediğimiz yapılardır. İlk kısımdaki
yardımcı eke bakacağız. Eğer is, are
bir tanesi ilk kısımda olumluysa ikinci
kısımda bunu olumsuz yapacağız. Eğer ilk
kısımda olumsuzsa diğer kısımda ise
olumlu yapacağız. Böylece karşıdaki
insana değil mi tarzında sorular
soracağız. İngilizcede eğer sahiplik
bildirmek istiyorsak yani bir şeye veya
birine ait olma durumundan bahsedeceksek
sahiplik zamirlerini kullanırız. Bunlara
possessive pronouns diyoruz. Oldukça
kolay. Birlikte inceleyelim.
Sahiplik zamirlerini öznelere göre teker
teker inceleyelim. I ben demektir. Eğer
benimki diyeceksek mine kullanacağız.
He, she ve it öznelerini inceleyelim. He
erkekler için kullanılır. Erkekler için
onunki diyeceksek his kullanırız. Kızlar
için onunki diyeceksek her kullanırız.
Cansız ve hayvanlarda onunki diyeceksek
eğer it öznesi varsa it diyeceğiz.
[homurdanır] birleşik şekilde yazılacak
kesme işareti kullanmıyoruz.
They onlar demektir. Eğer onlarınki
diyeceksek
kullanacağız. We biz demektir. Eğer
bizimki diyeceksek are kullanacağız. You
sen ya da siz demektir. Seninki ya da
sizinki diyeceksek yours kullanacağız.
Birlikte örnekleri inceleyelim.
I have a new camera.
Ben demektir. Bu tarafta ben dediğimiz
için diğer tarafta benimki diyeceğiz.
This camera is mine. Bu kamera benimki.
Mine benimki demektir. İlk kısımdaki
özneyi bulup daha sonra ona karşı gelen
sahiplik zamirini ekleyeceğiz.
Bir başka örnek daha inceleyelim. This
is Mike's gitar.
Bu Mike'ın gitarı. Mikes Mike'ın
demektir. Daha sonra bu gitar Mike'ın ki
diyeceğiz. The guitar ise
erkek ismi olduğu için erkekler de
onunki derken his kelimesini kullanırız.
We are camping. Biz camp yapıyoruz. This
big is ours. Bu büyük çadır bizimki. We
biz demektir. İlk tarafta biz kelimesini
kullandığımız için ikinci kısımda
bizimki derken ours ifadesini
kullanırız. Present progressive tense
yani şimdiki zaman. İngilizcenin en
temel, en çok kullanılan zamanlarından
bir tanesi. Eğer bunu bilirseniz temel
İngilizcede çok rahatlarsınız. Bu konu
oldukça önemli ve her zaman karşınıza
çıkacak olan konulardan bir tanesi. Hiç
telaşlanmayın. Oldukça kolay bir konu.
Benimle birlikte kısa zamanda
halledeceğiz.
Present progressive tense şimdiki zaman
demektir. Peki şimdiki zaman ne anlama
geliyor? Şimdiki zaman, şu an, şimdi
yani konuşma esnasında yaptığımız
işlerden bahsederken kullandığımız bir
zaman dilimidir. Yani siz şimdi
oturduğunuz yerden ben konuşurken ne
yapıyorsanız ondan bahsederken şimdiki
zaman kullanırsınız. Eğer önceden
planladığınız bir eylem varsa ve bu
eylem yakın zamanda da gerçekleşecekse
yine present progressive tense yani
şimdiki zaman kullanabilirsiniz. Biz
bunu Türkçede de yapıyoruz. Mesela yarın
Londra'ya uçuyorum. Aslında önceden
planladığınız biletini aldığınız bir
seyahat ve yakın gelecekte
gerçekleşecek. Bunu söylerken şimdiki
zamandan bahsedebilirsiniz.
Sürekli gerçekleşen ve hoşunuza gitmeyen
bir durumdan bahsederken yine şimdiki
zaman kullanabilirsiniz. Ve en son
değişen gerçek durumlardan bahsederken
şimdiki zaman kullanırız. Ama bilmeniz
gereken en önemli özelliği şimdi şu an
ne yapıyorsak ondan bahsedeceksek
şimdiki zaman kullanacağız.
Positive form olumlu hal demektir. Eğer
şimdiki zaman kullanarak olumlu yani
pozitif bir cümle elde edeceksek
cümleleri şu şekilde oluşturmalıyız.
İngilizcede her zaman cümleye bir özne
ile başlayacağız. Toplam 7 tane öznemiz
var. I, you, we, they, he, she ve it. Bu
öznelerden sonra is, are yardımcı
fiillerinden bir tanesini kullanacağız.
Bunlar öznelere göre değişiyor. Ardından
fiili kullanacağız. Ama dikkat etmeniz
gereken çok önemli bir nokta var. Fiil
her zaman eki ile kullanılır. Fiilin
yanına ekleyeceğiz. Daha sonra cümlenin
devamını yazacağız. Hangi özne ile
birlikte hangi yardımcı eki
kullanacağız? Teker teker inceleyelim. ı
öznesi ben demektir. I öznesi ile
birlikte yardımcı fiilini kullanırız.
He, she ve it özneleri ile birlikte is
yardımcı ekini kullanırız. Eğer kısa bir
şekilde yazacaksak kesme işaretiyle
ayırıp s yazacağız. He erkekler için
kullanılır, o demektir. She kızlar için
kullanılır, o demektir. It cansız ve
hayvanlarda kullanılır, o demektir.
Geriye kalan öznelere bakalım. They
onlar, we, biz, you, sen ya da siz
demektir. Bunlarla birlikte
kullanacağımız yardımcı ek aredır. Kısa
yazarken kesme işareti R ve E harflerini
kullanacağız. Yani öznelere göre
yardımcı ek kullandıktan sonra fiili
ekledik mi şimdiki zamanla ilgili
muhteşem bir cümle elde etmiş olacağız.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. Daha iyi
anlayacaksınız. I playing football.
Ben futbol oynuyorum. Ay öznedir, ben
demektir. A hangi yardımcı eki
kullanıyorduk? M. M yazdıktan sonra
play, oynamak fiiline ekleriz.
Gördüğünüz gibi bu kadar basit. She is
watching TV. O televizyon izliyor. She
kızlar için kullanılır. İstersek
herhangi bir kız ismi de kullanabiliriz.
Özneden sonra is yardımcı ekini
kullandık. Watch izlemek filmine ekini
ekledik. Şimdiki zamanla ilgili harika
bir cümle elde etmiş olduk. He is eating
pizza. O pizza yiyor. He özdesi yerine
herhangi bir erkek ismi de
kullanabiliriz. He öznesinden sonra is
yardımcı ekini kullandık ve fiile ekini
ekledik. The cat is sleeping. Kedi
uyuyor. Kedi yerine it de diyebiliriz.
Özneden sonra is yardımcı ekini
kullandık. Sleep uyumak fiilini ekini
ekledik. We are riding a bike. Biz
bisiklet sürüyoruz. We öznesi biz
demektir. Ondan sonra yardımcı ek olarak
are kullanılır. Sonra fiili ı ekini
ekledik. They are going to school. Onlar
okula gidiyorlar. They onlar demektir.
Onlar öznesinden sonra are yardımcı
ekini kullanırız. Go gitmek fiiline c
ekini ekleriz. You are catching a fish.
Sen balık yakalıyorsun. You özesinden
sonra are kullanırız. Catch yakalamak
fiilini ekini ekleriz. Ali and Aslı are
feeding the dog. Ali ve Aslı köpeği
besliyor. Eğer iki ve daha fazla kişiden
bahsedeceksek yani çoğul özde
kullanacaksak yardımcı ek olarak are
kullanırız. Daha sonra yine fiile
ekleriz. Yani çoğul öznelerde yardımcı
ekimiz yine are ifadesi. The birds are
flying. Kuşlar uçuyor. The birds
gördüğünüz gibi s çoğul ekini almıştır.
Çoğul öznelerde az önce söyledim.
Yardımcı ek olarak are kullanırız. Daha
sonra uçmak yani fly kelimesini ise
ekleriz. Olumlu cümle yapısı ile ilgili
bütün özneleri teker teker inceledik.
Şimdi sırada negative form yani olumsuz
negatif hal var. Eğer biz şimdiki zaman
kullanarak olumsuz bir cümle elde etmek
istiyorsak şu şekilde cümlelerimizi
oluşturabiliriz.
Yine her zamanki gibi cümleye bir özne
ile başlayacağız. Özneden sonra is,
are yardımcı eklerini kullanacağız. Ama
negatif yaparken bu sefer not kelimesine
ihtiyacımız var. Bunu da ekledikten
sonra fiile yine ekliyoruz ve cümlenin
devamını yazıyoruz. Öznelere göre
olumsuz hali teker teker inceleyelim.
Böylece aklınızda daha iyi kalacak. I
öznesi ile birlikte eğer olumsuz yapmak
istiyorsam hem not kullanırım. Eğer he,
she ve it öznelerinde olumsuz
kullanacaksam is not uzun hali, kısa
hali ise isn't. Bu arada daha çok kısa
haliyle karşınıza çıkacak. They, we
öznelerinde ise are not olumsuz hali,
uzun hali. Eğer bunu kısa yazacaksak
arız.
Peki kafanızda şöyle bir soru
şekillenmiş olabilir. Emnat ifadesini
uzun yazdık ama bunun kısa hali yok
mudur? Hayır yok. I not ifadesi
genelde uzun olarak yazılır. Yani not
olarak kısaltamayız.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. I not doing my
homework. Ben ödevimi yapmıyorum. Şu an
ödevini yapmıyor. Başka bir şeyle
ilgileniyor. Olumsuz kullandığı için ı
öznesinden sonra yardımcı ekini
kullandık. Not olumsuzluk ifadesini
yazdık. Yine fiili eki ekledik. She
isn't listening to music. O müzik
dinlemiyor. Şu an bilgisayarda başka bir
şey yapıyor. She özesinden sonra isn't
olumsuzluk ekini kullandık ve fiile
ekini ekledik. Eğer istersek is not
olarak uzun bir şekilde de yazabiliriz.
He isn't reading a newspaper. O gazete
okumuyor. He öznesinden sonra isn't
negatiflik ekini yazdık. Daha sonra
fiili ekini ekledik. It isn't raining.
Hava yağmurlu değil. Yağmur yağmıyor. It
öznesinden sonra negatif yapmak için
isn't kullandık. Rain. Yağmur yağma
ifadesine ise ekini getirdik. They ar't
joining the party tonight. Onlar bu gece
partiye katılmıyorlar. They onlar
demektir. Onlardan sonra negatif yapmak
için ar yardımcı ekini kullandık. Join,
katılmak ifadesine ekledik. We aren't
waiting for you. Biz senin için
beklemiyoruz. We öznesi biz demektir.
Arıntı yardımcı ekiyle negatif yani
olumsuz yaptık. Fiile ise c ekini
ekledik.
You arening home. Sen evi
temizlemiyorsun. US'sinden sonra ar
negatiflik eki gelir. He ile ek ekleriz.
Böylece şimdiki zamanda olumsuz negatif
bir cümle elde etmiş oluruz. Question
form soru hali demektir. Eğer şimdiki şu
anki eylemlerle ilgili karşımızdaki
insana soru soracaksak bunu nasıl
yapmalıyız?
Bu sefer öznelerle yardımcı ekler yer
değiştirecek. Yani cümleye is, are
yardımcı eklerinden bir tanesiyle
başladıktan sonra özneyi yazacağız.
Gördüğünüz gibi ikisi yer değiştirdi ve
fiil yine cini alacak. Daha sonra
cümlenin devamını yazıp soru işareti
koyacağız. Örnekleri inceleyelim. Are
you singing a song? Sen şarkı söylüyor
musun? Are yardımcı ekini kullandık.
Özneyi yazdıktan sonra fiili ekledik.
Eğer olumlu cevap vereceksek yes ı
Ama eğer olumsuz cevap vereceksek no
not diyeceğiz. Is she coming over for
dinner? O akşam yemeği için bize
uğrayacak mı? Is yardımcı ekini
kullandık. She özdesini yazdıktan sonra
fiil ı ekini ekledik. Eğer buna cevap
vereceksek, "Yes, she is." Ama eğer
olumsuz cevap vereceksek, "No, she isn't
demeliyiz.
Are they playing games?" Onlar oyun
oynuyorlar mı? Are yardımcı ekini
kullandıktan sonra özneyi yazdık. Play
oynamak filmine ekini ekledik. Eğer
olumlu cevap vereceksek yes, they are
ama eğer olumsuz cevap vereceksek no
they aren't demeliyiz. Şimdiki zaman
konusunda fiilleri c ekine ekleriz dedik
ama bu eki kafamıza göre ekleyemiyoruz.
Belli başlı kurallara dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor. Bu kurallar oldukça kolay.
Hiç telaş yapmanıza gerek yok. Örneğin
eğer bir ifadenin sonu yani
kullandığımız fiilin sonu bir sesli yani
ünlü bir de sessiz bir harfle bitiyorsa
sonundaki ünsüz harfi iki kere yazarız.
Örneğin run fiilini inceleyelim. Run
koşmak demektir. Sonundaki u harfi ünlü,
n harfi ünsüzdür. Bir sesli bir sessiz.
G eklerken sonundaki n harfini iki kere
yazarız. running şeklinde. Swim yüzmek
demektir. En sonundaki iki tane
harfeyuz. I harfi ünlü, M harfi ünsüz.
Yazarken swimming şeklinde yazacağız.
Yani iki tane M harfiyle. Sit oturmak
demektir. Sonundaki i harfi ünlü, T
harfi ünsüzdür. Bunu yazarken sonundaki
t harfinden iki tane yazacağız. İkinci
kural ise eğer bir fiilin sonu i ve e
harfiyle bitiyorsa bunları sileceğiz.
Onun yerine y harfini yazacağız. Örneğin
lay fiili sonu i ve e harfiyile bitiyor.
Bunları yazarken yani c eki eklerken
sonundaki i ve e harfini siler. Onun
yerine y harfini ekleriz ve yazarız. Day
ölmek demektir. I ve e harfiyle bitiyor.
Bunu yazarken yani buna ekleyeceksek y
harfini yazarız. Diğerlerini sileriz.
3üncü kural ise sonu e harfiyle biten
fiiller. Eğer sonu e harfiyle bitiyorsa
eki geldiğinde e harfini yazmıyoruz.
Make yapmak demektir. Gördüğünüz gibi
geldiğinde E harfini sildik. Write
yazmak demektir. Eğer sonunda E harfi
varsa ve biz buna ekleyeceksek E harfini
siliyoruz. Ama burada dikkat etmeniz
gereken bir şey var. E harfinden önce
eğer ünlü bir harf varsa değişiklik
olmaz. Örneğin C görmek demektir. E
harfiyle bitiyor. Ama ondan önce de bir
tane E harfi yani ünlü harf var. Bu
sefer değiştirmeyeceğiz. Sonuna direkt
ing yazacağız. Time expression zaman
ifadeleri demektir. Şimdiki zamanda
kullanabileceğimiz zaman ifadeleri
şunlardır. These days bugünlerde.
This morning bu sabah. Today bugün. Now
şu an. Şimdi right now şu anda. Tam da
şu an. At the moment. Şimdi şu anda. At
present. Şu an şu sıralar. Tonight bu
gece. This week bu hafta. Still. hala ya
da cümlelerde look geçiyorsa bak, listen
geçiyorsa dinle. Bunlar da şimdiki
zamanda kullanabileceğimiz fiillerdir.
Nowadays ise bugünlerde demektir.
Bunları cümlelerinizin sonunda ya da
başında kullanarak şimdi şu andan
bahsettiğinizi söyleyebilirsiniz. Birkaç
tane örnek inceleyelim. The students are
studying lesson right now. Öğrenciler
şimdi ders çalışıyorlar. Gördüğünüz gibi
now ifadesi şu an şimdi demekti. Onu
kullanarak şimdiki zaman olduğunu
belirttik. Look outside it is snowing.
Dışarıya bak kar yağıyor. Look ifadesini
de kullanarak şimdiki zaman olduğunu
belirtebiliriz. We are looking for a new
house at present. Biz şimdilerde şu
anlarda yine eve bakıyoruz. At present
şimdilerde şu anda demektir. Posive case
yani sahiplik bildirme durumu bir şeyin
kime, neye ait olduğunu bildirmek için
kullandığımız yapılardır. Sahiplik
durumunu İngilizcede şu şekilde
bildiririz. Bir isim yazdıktan sonra
kesme işaretiyle S harfini kullanırsak
bu sahiplik yani aitlik bildirme durumu
olur. Örnekleri inceleyelim. Ayşe's car
is in the garage. Ayşe'nin arabası
garajda. Gördüğünüz gibi arabanın
Ayşe'nin olduğunu vurgulamak istiyorsak
Ayşe'den sonra kesme işareti
kullanacağız ve S harfi yazacağız.
İngilizcede aitlik bildirimin en kısa
yolu budur. My father's office is near
home. Benim babamın ofisi eve yakın. My
father benim babam demektir. Benim
babamın demek istiyorsak kesme işareti
kullanıp S harfi ekleyeceğiz. Benim
babamın ofisi. Ahmet's book is on the
table. Ahmet'in kitabı masanın üzerinde.
Ahmet'ten sonra kesme işareti kullanıp S
harfini yazdık.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.
Play Store ve App Store'dan Justin
Academy uygulamasını indirip kullanmayı
unutmayın lütfen.